this podcast is brought to you by gray
block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard in Los
Angeles also bronx-born pizza up in Bend
Oregon we are grateful to both of those
places for their support since pretty
much day one we wouldn't be here today
if it weren't for them this past weekend
is brought to you by Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design technology and more
I mean it's so quickly there's a skill
right now that you probably want to have
there's something that I want to have
and and you can have them and you can
have them now you can have them but some
of them you can have by the end of
tonight and you can do that right now at
skill share calm you can take classes in
social media marketing data science
mobile photography creative writing you
name it they've got it so whether you're
trying to deepen your professional skill
set start a little sod hustle you know
if you want to you know she sells
seashells by the seashore you know
that's beautiful just explore a new
passion you can do that skill share is
there to keep you learning and thriving
you want to class go take it join the
millions of students already learning on
skills here today with a special offer
just for my listeners get two months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents that's
right skill share is offering this past
weekend listeners two months of
unlimited access to over 20,000 classes
for just 99 cents to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo again go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo to start your
two months now that's Skillshare dot-com
slash Theo this weekend I'll be in
Pasadena on Wednesday August 8th at the
Pasadena ice house tickets available
Theo von comm slash tour as well in two
weeks I'll be at the Laugh Factory in
Chicago after that Nashville also
Charlotte we just added some dates I'm
heading back to that North Carroll akka
and that is October 4th through the
Toronto Appleton Buffalo Salt Lake City
you guys all tickets available at Theo
von comm slash tour you know sometimes
you want you see that swimming pool you
you jump in you don't know how deep it
is that's why I'm at today you know
sometimes you jump into a pool and it's
beautiful you just get wet
sometime you jump in and you that bottom
is two inches down and that water had
that little you know it that's a mirage
that's a damp Mirage and sometimes you
don't get wet you get straight-up
handicapped sometimes you get wet
sometimes you get wheelchair so who
knows but this is where we are right now
we're flying by the seat of our pants
and we're in the air unless let's hit
this pool let's see how deep this thing
is
[Music]
mm-hm
it's a little hitter right here look
Betty
[Music]
this is 200
is 200 miles I just sit on laughing
smile please wear that old evil honesty
Memphis where that old evil woman
scattered ship on a shoulder since the
day she left dad
[Music]
he was bored around she made her mama
cry she didn't
that's about time
who was
to get laid my heart just like a guitar
and she didn't skip a beat now
she's short for
200 miles Memphis is where that old evil
woman stays man everybody's got an evil
woman in the distance don't they and it
might be an actual it might be an actual
woman you know it might be that dirty
damsel you know it might be that little
dandruff that little dandruff damsel in
the distance that just man you just
can't help but scratch your head when it
comes to thinking about that woman but
then it might be a pervert you know not
even a real woman just a hypothetical a
woman it might be a thing an object it
might be just something you know it
could be a drug in the distance that you
keep far away it could be a it could be
a memory that you rid that you're hiding
from or you're running from or this at
you that you steer clear of you know it
could be it could be something that you
keep at arm's length you know we all
have things and you know we don't know
who knows if we all have things I have
things that I keep at arm's length you
know I have some I have some things that
I keep you know I have some truths that
I keep at arm's length you know I don't
always want to be fully honest with
myself you know I think it's it's
interesting how a wild it is to be to be
fully on to fully honest if I want to
tell myself the hundred percent truth I
don't know I don't want to do that you
know I don't want to do that I get
scared to tell him myself the truth what
the truth man what if I'm fully honest
with myself what could happen you know
and that's one of my goals this year and
the rest of this year is to get fully
honest with myself you know dude should
live in the just to others don't mana
and I don't they and I don't have a lot
of skeletons in the closet but damn boy
you could hear some femurs just acting
fancy in there once in a while you know
and the crazy thing about honesty the
crazy thing about the truth the truth I
feel like carries a drum the truth
carries a drama in the beginning of your
high view when you have the truth and
you don't let the truth free when the
truth is free you can't hear it but when
you put that truth away it gets us a
little drum out and it'll just start
making a little sound and a little sound
and then that sound just keepsake sound
grows in you until that truth is just
[ __ ] Jerry page or whatever or you
know what I'm saying
[ __ ] lonnie Van Zandt back there just
beaten the hell out of that thing and
then you just dang man the truth will
not he just you know that's just that
sound and it just wants to get out and
that's the truth is the truth wants to
be quiet but it has to be free and when
you got that true caged up boy that
thing can get really loud and that's
where I'm at sometimes just living
sometimes you know I just want to live
it come I want to live on that plane of
just freedom
and so that's one of my goals this year
to get even closer to that plane if I
can and it's a journey I don't think
that's that's all like there's no right
here in a journey you know we're out
here in this rowboat you ever bought a
bad boat off of somebody you ever bought
a bad boat you're like damn dude look at
that [ __ ] boat man and they're like
oh it's a good boat and you're like okay
here's some money then you're out in
that [ __ ] and you're like what the [ __ ]
dude
this boat is bad and that's life
sometimes you start to think about this
you're get you get life at zero at
you're like four days old you get to be
alive two days or whatever
six minutes old and you get that right
out the gate you get life and then you
out there twenty thirty years you're
like the ham what it's Tang this life's
got a few holes in it my life's taking
on water and I got to dry this thing out
and it's in it's hard man it's hard
because you don't know you don't know
that you know you just don't [ __ ]
know whatever I don't know what I'm
talking about you just keep rowing brah
you just keep rowing it's not always
going the way you want brah but onward
right what's up thank you guys for being
here I'll just go back from Minneapolis
I want to thank everybody that came out
I got back from Rochester I worked with
Gary Vaynerchuk this weekend and Gary
Vaynerchuk man he's that mahi you know
he's that money-minded little you know
he's that little dollar monster
you know he's that money muppet and he
likes money he likes business you know
he's like that Brit you know he's like
the Walter White of [ __ ] Wall Street
you know he's he talks about money he
talks about business he talks about
succeeding and look I you know I've seen
videos of his on Facebook and I was like
what is this guy is this for real what's
his deal and I'll tell you this from
walking around with you know I was out
there with this group called stationary
astronaut we're in Rochester Minnesota
and and it was great and I sat in the
back he not performed last the cut the
comedians were going on at the end and
Gary Vaynerchuk
was a big draw there and people brought
tickets to go see him and some people
bought tickets to come seeing me and we
did the show and and it was great man it
was a great experience and Gary
Vaynerchuk man he gave out some good
advice he gave us some good advice
here's a couple things that he said he
said and I'll do you know like I'm just
sharing this information and I heard
with you now and this is stuff that I
took that I thought was helpful he said
that um he thought that right now these
are simple things might mean nothing to
nobody
that that land that that you could get
real estate in New York for pennies on
the dollar right now he thought and
another thing that he said was that
advertising on Instagram and Facebook
are cheaper than they will ever be or as
cheap as they will ever be so that you
utilize those tools and he also just I
think he genuinely wants people just to
be to be woke you know to be woke up
when it comes to business if they want
to do business now some people it's like
you know you were infected with this
world where everything you got to do
business you know and Gary Vaynerchuk
seemed like that money muffin you know
he got that bang like if you say if Wiis
all Muppets because we saw and somebody
put a hand up you who gots a hand whose
hand is in your butt is making you live
your life whose hand is up you is up
your skirt up your full-body skirt you
know and making you Muppet is it a is
that person a therapist is that person a
banker and Gary Vaynerchuk whoever you
know whatever hand is coming to him
it's that money hand you know it's that
banker hand and he likes money and he
likes business and I think he just likes
effectiveness but it was interesting man
and and it was a blast very good time
there in Rochester in Rochester
Minnesota if there's a city on earth
where there are angels at man its
Rochester Minnesota I mean this city
first of all the Mayo Clinic is there
and the Mayo Clinic you know when I was
young some people know and some people
don't my sister was suffered from a rare
liver disease called biliary atresia and
it's affects one and maybe almost half a
million children and their something
with their liver their bile duct or
something doesn't work and you know I
remember as a kid man it would be so
crazy because we couldn't touch our
little sister
you know and we couldn't like hug her
and we couldn't play with her because
she was sick and so it was you know I
think some of my connectivity issues and
stuff I think a lot of my intimacy
issues maybe even developed right there
you know like you know and I and you
don't realize it when you're a kid as
much but you know it makes you kind of
scared that you can't you know that you
have a little girl that's sick and a
little girl that's sick and then you
can't touch her you know you can't play
with her you're scared you're gonna hurt
her or something because she had to wear
like a bag you know sometimes and she
had to you know I remember she would go
away and uh and she was two years
younger than me so she would go away and
she'd come back with all these scars on
her you know they would you know you
know they'd carve anew her a little bit
she come back looking like uh you know
like a that that that Thanksgiving
turkey about three hours into the end of
the end of the giving you know I'm
saying I mean that turkey gave you know
if on Thanksgiving say turkey dinners at
1:00 you you go take a gander you know
I'm saying you drop eyeballs on that
[ __ ] Turkey about 3:30 in the
afternoon that thing looks like it's
been in a damn gangbang with a couple of
knives you know a couple of connives and
that's how my sister came back you know
she come back to look kind of chopped up
and she'd have these sutures and
everything and and it's so funny I never
thought about that that that could have
been something that kind of you know may
be adjusted how I interact with people
are especially women even or anybody
sometimes in like a spatial kind of you
know physical spatial type of
environment but yeah but we couldn't
touch her we couldn't play with her and
she would be sick and it was just kind
of scary anyway there was a point when
and and she would go all over the
country because it was very rare at the
time and my sister ended up getting a
liver transplant and uh
and that was crate you know I remember
being real young and and we would do
fundraisers and we would take those cans
around town and put the cans out you
know at the pizza parlors and whatever
for people to put money in the cans form
up for my sister you know to raise money
for a transplant because she needed it
she needed constant care and she needed
a transplant to get that extra liver you
know I'm saying she need that extra
[ __ ] straight-up body hit her bra and
that livers are they dude that liver
whoo that liver bro that's the Patrick
Swayze of organs liver could do anything
you've been drinking bye-bye oh boy
liver will shine you up and put you back
on and you go to work the next day but
I'll you know the Sam your livers right
there you delivers got your front you
livers got your back you know your liver
will ring you out and tighten you up and
and so anyway man you know she ended up
getting a transplant years later but
when I was young she had to go to the
Mayo Clinic and the Mayo Clinic is there
in Rochester it's right there in
Rochester Minnesota and you're talking
about you're talking about a hospital
that I want to say they see there's like
a million almost a million and a half
patients that come through there every
year and so some of you guys are
thinking that's crazy
that's a unrealistic amount of patient
and this is this is a small city let me
look up the population of Rochester
Rochester Minnesota population is 114
thousand okay people live in Rochester
Minnesota
but the Mayo Clinic brings in over a
million people pass through that city
every year and and that's amazing so you
want to talk about a place where you
know we're good is happening and you can
feel it in the air man you could feel
there were so many nice people it was
unbelievable even if they had thugs in
there the dudes were [ __ ] nice you
know you know I mean you it's the kind
of place where if you even if you got
mugs I'm do it like give me all your
money you know if you kind of okay with
that give me all your money if you don't
you know you
you could you know and I'll give it
right back like that kind of thing
notice that kind of place where there's
just a lot of good in the air up there
and it was just a blessing to be there
maybe cuz I was back there and because
here's what happened was when my sister
went one time when we were kids we got
to go up and see her because it was a
holiday it was Christmas and so we got
to go spend a Christmas up there in
Rochester Minnesota when I was a child
and visit my sister up there at the Mayo
Clinic and they have a huge Ronald
McDonald House up there and everything
but anyway it was just amazing man I had
a great time and I got to listen to Gary
Vaynerchuk and it was cool you know it
was just cool one thing I realized about
being listening to like inspirational
speakers because I don't do that kind of
stuff that much you know I'll watch the
Tony Robbins documentary that came up
this year but one thing is um you know
it's and I probably had some judgments
about Gary Vee I'm like look at this
he's just you know this guy was born his
family was wealthy they had a wealthy
wine business and bla bla bla and what
is you know which struggle is he had and
bla bla bla those the thoughts going
through my head but then he was
inspiring and sometimes it's good to
just hear somebody inspire you and
that's what I realized like I don't care
like I might not maybe I agree with
everything this guy says I don't know
maybe I don't but the guys has achieved
a lot of successes and he's speaking to
me in an inspirational way he wants me
to leave here better than I came he
wants me to leave here more inspired and
it was good and that's how I felt I left
there more inspired had a couple of new
ideas and I left there more inspired but
people were so friendly man everybody
was so friendly and I have a stationary
astronaut group that brought me out was
was amazing that song on the way in was
by Brooks Doherty and you could check
that out we'll put a link to that if
there is one in the YouTube and in the
comments and that's Brooks Brooks
Doherty
and and yeah we've all got those truths
or those things that we keep or that
woman or that X or that we've all got
something that we keep about 200 miles
away we've all got something we keep at
arm
length you know we've all got something
that you know it's hard to you know
sometimes and sometimes that's where it
needs to be
sometimes that's where it needs to be
thank you everybody that came out of
Minneapolis um look I'll be honest that
theater was a dump and it was and the
staff was great I'm not saying that the
staff was it wasn't great man they had a
young man there who we didn't have it
there was no lighting to take photos
afterwards the microphone wasn't why it
wasn't a wire mic like you know the
stage and I just say this to apologize
I'm not even really trying I'm not
trying to offend the venue you know the
plate just it is what it is right I've
never been there I didn't know what it
was like I think we made the best of the
situation the stage had a hill it had
this like messed up part in the flooring
of the stage where when I stepped on it
it like made this didn't sound it sent
out this Morse code so as I'm walking
around to dunt dunt dunt
and and so then the first shot couldn't
even I couldn't even be mobile because
there was no way to walk back and forth
there was like a little hill almost in
the middle of the stage so it just made
it extremely uncomfortable and the
lighting would there was lighting the
lighting wasn't good you know they had
these these very dim purple lights on us
so I want to apologize to the people
that came out to the first show the
second show they got the lights going
you know I said hey man we got to turn
these lights up what is this and we had
them fixed the stage and make it flat
because like it's a stage should be flat
and and they helped out man they
adjusted as much you know accordingly
and the second show I felt like we
really were able to really just do
better it still wasn't ideal you know I
had a lot of fans that reached out and
you know made comments and stuff and I'm
sorry you know I want to apologize I
didn't know
and so I feel some responsibility
because I want it to be the best I want
it to be look man I'm excited to come
and I wanted to be there and I don't
know I just felt like I let some people
down a little bit uh but but anyhow well
you know if we go back there again we'll
make sure everything's shined up or
we'll go some
where else or we'll see how it goes but
um but I was definitely grateful to be
there and we you know both shows were
sold out and you know we've got some
great pictures afterwards with the strap
and I wish the lighting had been better
I know they did the best they could they
brought him like some floodlights from a
construction site or something okay
sometimes that's how we have to do it
and people in Minnesota are so kind and
friendly that everybody was so
supportive I saw a couple of mullets out
there and uh you know what's interesting
about the mullet man what's interesting
about it is so look so I have this
haircut and to me this feels like just a
regular adult man's haircut you know the
kind of guy who definitely is down the
[ __ ] you know but also has some erectile
issues you know what I'm saying that's
that patented straight-up modern man cut
you know what I'm saying I'm talking
about half-mast baby you want that penis
and it's gonna be kind of you know it'll
be decently long but it's gonna be a
little bit squishy you know if you want
that super hard kick you know you might
want to go travel back in time about 20
years when that thing was really
pertinent but uh or when I was about 17
you know when I was just full running it
on full spring cuz also some people
don't even know this uh you know I was
born when I was about five maybe four or
five years old I had an adult penis at
four or five and some people were like
what are you talking about and what I'm
talking about is exactly what I just
said is that I had that I had that ap
you know that early that a delt pianist
you know and I'm talking about [ __ ]
you know Vincent van you know that I had
that Vincent van gang bro you know I had
that straight up that pianist and I know
Vincent van Gogh isn't a P is it didn't
play the piano but I had that [ __ ]
Vincent van gang that pianist you know
that human adult pianist at five years
old and a lot of people think it's cool
stuff having a man's penis having them
you know that emcees you that man kick
at a young age but it isn't you know
it's heavy
it's strange strain on your legs on the
side of your legs even strains on your
shoulders and stuff a little but here
was the crazy part and I grew into my
penis and this happens it's very rare it
happens in few people you know probably
maybe I think I don't know if I've seen
a lot of numbers I had up I mean I had
all kinds of pee nihilist she was
growing up and that's crazy we've talked
about some of them before you know had a
very small wiener hole and so when I
would urinate it would I mean you know
what I'm saying I could I could hit a
[ __ ] soybean on the cat's back from
probably about maybe nine feet away and
that is I mean and I could just and I
could even here's what I could do I
could wash a cup I could washer a couple
pieces of sea salt off the top of a
soybean on a cat's back so that fine
that's fine of a stream because I had a
small I don't know what it's called and
a doctor would know better than I would
had a very small wiener hole and that's
what people call it that aren't doctors
and and I had that thing and so I could
you know I had that flow but then I had
to go and get it surgically opened up
because it was too I mean it got to the
point where I was getting older and it
was 13 feet 14 feet you know when people
are paying money to see me piss and it
would just get crazy and and it burned
and it burned the inside of my body
anyhow but I had an adult man's penis at
a young age and and the hard part about
having that when you're young is that
trying to sleep you think it's walking
around and stuff okay you get used to
that you know your body get kind of your
thighs get strong you know your thighs
get real [ __ ] ready because they have to
do you know they have to transport you
know real [ __ ] every day even a young
age but but sleeping and if you somehow
my words fall asleep on my own wiener
I'm kidding I'm talking about this but I
fall asleep on my own wiener and it
would make me sick because the pressure
of it is pushing against my young belly
at night would make me almost vomit but
anyhow are we talking about Gary Varner
mmm
we're talking about uh your body no
we're talking about oh I don't know
thank you to the Mayo Clinic thank you
everybody came out of Minneapolis I
still had a great time and what are we
talking about your body we're talking
about growing up no we're talking about
when I was young [ __ ] I don't know sorry
guys I got a gift you know people bring
you gifts sometimes on the road some man
brought me a couple of G pig skulls
couple guinea pigs
you know then [ __ ] Guinea craniums
you know and I'm not talking about
Italians I'm talking about the small
animals and it's a couple of dude
brought me a couple guinea craniums and
I don't know how this dude got it I mean
this and I will I'll try to put a
picture of him in here he brought me the
skulls of guinea pigs and then they were
all doctored up you know he had
literally dark-hearted them and he you
know made him fancy and I mean these are
the kind of things that this has had a
little bit of witchery you know a little
bit of Wiccan and this was uh and they
were beautiful one of them said onward
and one of them said Dark Arts and there
are beautiful little skulls and I don't
know if he did you know I've been doing
soup or what he been doing but but that
was a nice gift I got another gift that
came in I'm just gonna show it to you
and people bring things sometimes uh you
know sometimes I bring him on this
person was I don't this is a t-shirt
somebody brought me in and it stinks
honestly and that's okay and I just you
know this this shirt was given to me
years back by my friend Garrett this is
a letter that came with a shirt I don't
get much action with it I just look like
I'm drowning in nacho cheese it's kind
of a yellow it is definitely a color
that's very rare
anyway Garrett's in Peru right now
teaching English to young adults as you
know being in another country can get
lonely I sent him a link to your podcast
videos and he is loving that [ __ ] he's
been doing better and learning to love
himself he was stoked that I'm getting
to see you tonight
so this was given to me in Minneapolis
this weekend and it says
thank you for what you're doing Luke
Lucas Tanger and Luke Thank You Man and
when I uh
and I appreciate the shirt dude and I
will you know this smell like another
man and that's the thing brother
you know maybe didn't even it might be
clean but it smells like another man is
hard bro it's hard as an adult male to
put on another man's shirt I mean when I
have us so much of that man in it I mean
this man has had this shirt for probably
seem like about eight years that's a lot
a man already baked in to that thread
count that's like about probably maybe
maybe 70 thread count cotton and maybe
forty thread count mail and that's a lot
and you know that it just makes you feel
uncomfortable as a man as a straight man
now as a gay man it could feel
differently I don't know you know
there's some things that make me feel
why like that I just they're hard to do
if you've ever if a man has gotten out
of bed you've ever laid in that man's
bed immediately in his warm spot and
you're a straight man that is that is
you know that does something to your
neck boy that'll make squirrels start
nibbling at your neck you know and if
her gay man it might be fun it might be
you know it might be like you know body
heat freeze tag or something I don't
know what that's like and there's
nothing wrong with that you know it
would make sense that that's a more of a
comfortable realm you know for that 98.6
[ __ ] a little love cave if you
snuggle up in that thing if your man's
gets out of bed but as a straight man
and if another man gets out you know say
if you climb into a dudes bed and he's
been in there and you snuck in you know
and he left to work or something you've
been sleeping in his house on the couch
with no covers and your buddy finally
goes to work and you [ __ ] want to
catch two more hours of Z's cuz you was
stayed up all night sipping on x'mas you
know I mean watching Judge Judy then now
you can and you go slip into his bed but
you catch up there's still a little bit
of his warmth in there
that'll make it tango boy that'll make
you tangle it makes you feel like just
[ __ ] somebody is just beating you in
the neck with a [ __ ] bunch of soft
little shovels it makes you feel
uncomfortable but that's how this shirt
makes me feel a little bit and I'm
grateful for this shirt it's got Michael
Jackson on it but also you know and I'm
thankful to Garrett and everybody but uh
but it's hard to wear another man's
shirt like that but the beauty and it is
even when the place isn't ideal and even
when the show doesn't go because the
lights because they're you know they're
try they're changing the lights in the
middle of it and the sound that I didn't
have a wired microphone in the joint
that they that we get to have moments
like this where somebody comes out and
maybe a nice note and you share it Luke
and you share it you're not afraid to
share some you know with something with
somebody else and you're not afraid to
and that's nice man in this room this
meant a lot to me and I brought it back
here to this podcast and I want to thank
you very much man we also got this this
a postcard came in and I'll put that
into our we do an anthrax challenge
where we open up a lot of mail every
month and we'll put one of those up
maybe at the end of this week as well we
had a single mom that came out Emily so
it was a lot of fun man we went to eat
before at a place like literally right
across the street and there were some
people that were headed to the show and
we had a nice time and we'll do follow
up with her to see you guys can get a
look at that we shot a little bit of
video and and thank you to so many
people have reached out to help out in
different cities and start to do some
cinematography and videography for us
and things are gonna get things are
coming along we're gonna do some neat
stuff dude I got this idea that I want
to do like a game show for meit like a
cleaning lady in a hotel room right
because I've had some experience with
cleaning ladies dude one time you know
some little vixen you know some little
eye some little eye you know some little
love Daisy some little lady some little
Fraulein some little uh you know
whispery you know whispery little wiener
monkey some beautiful lady or maybe not
even beautiful but decent looking mmm
stayed over in my hotel room right and
she had in the middle of the night you
know something happened and I'm not
saying we did sex or anything like that
we might have just been friends we might
have [ __ ] arm-wrestled bruh I'm
saying I don't know that [ __ ] might
have been from New Jersey you know we
might have done each other's hair and
arm-wrestled who knows but a lady stayed
over and she had a mother nature hit her
in the middle of the night you know hit
her down in that you know and that a
positive aqueduct you know she got a
little bit of that period and I know
that's kind of vulgar and I'm not trying
to talk about it but she got a little
bit of that Mintz trial you film me you
know I'm saying she got a little bit of
that you know that Oh negative aqueduct
kind of opened up the little bit and and
that's natural dude that's totally
natural you know I can only imagine if
they had eggs moving around in my body
I'd want to [ __ ] you know take a
little heat off the engine every now and
then you know and do that you know and
do a little bit of men's trou but so
anyway you know um you know and it was
okay was you know we just kind of joked
about it in the morning cuz I wet the
bed till I was 30 30 you know I think
the last time I really you know flowed
out was when I was 30
you know nice did you know just straight
up run big yell out into the sheets and
especially when I was a child right
because I would drink so much apple
juice and man I pissed big on apple
juice bruh
nobody I'll tell you this and I'll put
this up against any any child in America
no child could wet the bed like I could
when I was really out there as a child
and I was pissing that night dude I
could wet the bed four times in a night
son I'm out in these sheets treats baby
you want to change these sheets change
them you better invite some ghosts over
to the house because we need more sheets
you better invite a couple of clans my
no behalf because we need to borrow some
bedding baby cuz I'm gonna piss every
sheet in this house though I'd wake up
three four times a night to change the
sheets I'd wake up everybody if you had
me sleep at your house dude I was that
little mattress wrecker you know I was
that little dude I was just I'd be
rusting up the springs in that thing boy
you better put me on you know what I'm
saying by the third time I stay to your
house they had me sleeping in the doll
bed
I'm snuggling up between a shih tzu and
a Weimaraner because my wiener gets
Wiener running straight up just dropping
urine out another world and I would just
urinate I mean the second I closed my
eyes I think I was just if anything I
think I was scared of the dark and I
would piss myself
I don't did it but if I had apple juice
if daddy had a little sip of that AJ
because the second I had any apple juice
I had it all I could hide a gallon in my
gullet but then in the middle of the
night I would flow out I mean I could
just urinate anyway so this girl you
know she had some minstrel and I had to
tell the cleaning lady about it because
I felt bad you know I felt I didn't feel
responsibility but I felt like you know
this accidents happened things happen
this is life we're in the world for 80
years somebody's gonna do a little bit
of minstrel you know and and so anyway
cleaning ladies have to deal with stuff
like that's what I'm saying is I would
love to do a thing where would you like
this surprise game show in the hotel
room for a cleaning lady you know like
she's in there suddenly we surprise or
jump out from behind some curtains and I
don't want somebody [ __ ] you know
beating me down with a straight up one
of them toilet cleanser things you know
or beating me down with a can of Comet
or something or straight-up Windex and
daddy in the face I don't want it you
know so we have to be careful but they
maybe we do a couple of questions or
something ever win some money or
something I don't know but uh but that
would be another neat thing to do out on
the road but um but we'll see man we're
getting more we're slowly it's slow is
slow here but we're getting the wheels
turning what else I want to tell you
guys but that's what happens man no
matter what when we're out on the road
it's the greatest set up it's not that
most ideal set up you guys come out and
we have a good time you know when we get
the job done and we and we meet up and
we spend time together and it wasn't the
most ideal way to spend time together
after the shows I like to spend a little
bit more time you know and I felt
flustered I want to apologize to the
people that came out to the first show
that just we weren't able to create more
organization in there and and that won't
happen again just because I valued that
time you're not flying out there to do
this I want to put on you know I want
this to be a great experience I want
this to be a lot of fun you know I feel
grateful to be able to to to be you know
joking around and I feel grateful that
we're all doing you know we're out here
doing this what else man
but that's a beautiful city Mayo Clinic
Rochester Minnesota if you want to you
want to go to a place you know they say
you go to a place where there's you know
people go to the wizard wall or whatever
and on Israel or or Palestine or they go
to the you know they go to I don't know
what that place is called Jerry's
volcano or whatever someplace you know
where there think there's like magic you
know Old Faithful they have what else
Bermuda Triangle places where they think
there's magic in the world you want to
know about one of those go to Rochester
Minnesota because the love that has to
be in that city you know I was talking
to a bartender that worked there and she
said you know it's really tough because
if you if you if you're serving a drink
to somebody and and you say where are
you from if they say from a different
town or a different city then you know
they're probably in the city because
someone that they and that they love or
somebody in their family needs long-term
care so she said it's kind of wild
because you have to have conversations
constantly with people where there's
real feelings involved where there's
real emotions and and I think that
special man there's something about that
you know where life is on the line you
know where life is on the line and
people are out there you know doing
their best to love one another and I can
imagine and that's as
to be a special place they have going on
up there and I don't know if a city
could if every state could do it but
Minnesota can do that because they got a
lot of big hearts up there you know a
lot of their brain is in their heart and
the other stuff in their head the brain
in their head that just wants cheese and
it wants to cheer for the Vikings
but that real brain in their heart meant
a thing is uh is thinking and thinking
about love all the time oh my in what
else dude I'm freaking what's going on
oh you know kind of struggling with some
stuff in my life I've been struggling
the bike um you know I just don't I just
want to do you know it's hard to in
business man I'm doing business I don't
like doing I like I like staying busy
but sometimes I don't like doing
business because it it makes me feel
sometimes dirty I thought that makes any
sense
it makes some busy like I don't know it
just makes me feel it's uncomfortable
sometimes you know you want to do you
want to succeed you want to achieve but
I don't I don't know it's just I don't
know what else we got some we got some
dope calls that came I'm not really
switching gears yet we got something we
got Jocko willing coming on this week a
Navy SEAL I mean this man has done it
all very inspirational and I'm hoping to
catch some more inspiration from him
we got Jeanie buss the daughter of uh
you know that she's that Laker lady and
they just got LeBron James over there
the daughter of Jerry Buss and we're
gonna talk about some things I'm excited
she's beautiful lady extremely charming
so I'm excited to spend some time with
her you know we got some some feedback
that came in last week's episode we
talked about if you had to have lunch
with somebody and you could have lunch
with one other person who would it be
I talked about some family members that
I would have lunch with
and and then you guys made some calls
and so I want to get to a couple of
those calls thank you for those here we
go hey it's Sophie here from Nova Scotia
Canada and Oh Sophie up from that skosh
huh from that no skosh and uh ASCO swear
I'm from a skosh is just a little bit of
space
you know like won't you move them
breasts on over a skosh you know that
was one of my pickup lines in junior
high school you know why don't you move
in brass on over a skosh and then I get
slapped dude I remember now and I'm
thinking about it when I was in you know
junior high and uh and that's when a lot
of girls first start letting you know be
wild which are actually this was in high
school this was in high school when I
was in high school
a lot of ladies they let you start
getting a little bit you know everybody
had their bodies just on Front Street
actually their brains and their their
hormones were on Front Street in their
bodies were right there on bat women
kind of had their bodies on back street
men had their bodies on Front Street you
know what I'm saying you'd hear do not
hear a dog howling and I'd have to jerk
off you know and not and look people
know and I joke about that kind of stuff
and I've struggle with it and Here I am
you know twenty you know twenty years
later still not the same thing but if I
see two dogs fighting bruh I get a
little chub DUP you know I'm still
battling these dark hearts man I'm still
battling just keeping my hands off my
dang off moon dang lang anyhow what was
I saying
my brain is dead today what was uh oh
Oh somebody called in where was this
call from let's started again
hey yeah it's Sophie here from Nova
Scotia Canada and oh yeah that's coach
you try to get the ladies to move on
over a skosh well I remember when I was
in you know when I was young when I was
a child and I was getting to be a tall
child and look here's the crazy thing
about me I had that meant you know I had
that adult wiener and my body was
constantly trying to catch up to my dick
and that's how that's hectic for a kid
you know just to feel your body just
kind of racing it's almost like your
body's chasing your penis because you
have that adult sized penis in your body
just you know so I would get tall pretty
fast I'd hit these spurts you know my
body would just Carl Lewis overnight and
then I would be you know seven inches
taller the next day they'd I'd fall
asleep in a in a long shirt I'd fall
asleep in a large and I'd wake up in a
medium that's how it was I mean that's
when you you know I'd sprout a couple
ribs I'd sprout four ribs overnight I
fall asleep with six ribs and I wake up
with damn nine or ten you know ten
because they come in two at a time and
that's just how it is when you're young
your body's growing and especially uh
anyway I remember in high school you
know a lot of girls you know guys were
so eager and girls were still you know a
lot of you know girls it's there they
got to protect the body because men are
nature is out there were like we're that
electric current you know and women um
they don't want you hanging out in their
socket and I remember this one yeah and
she uh you know but she cared about me
and she was what she would do she said
well how about this I can't make you
know I can't let you touch my body but
I'll go in the other room and this would
be at night we'd be over at her parents
house and she'd go in the other room in
the dining room and her parents would be
asleep she got let you sit here in the
kitchen and listen and I go in the
dining room and play with my breath
and uh and so man I would but you don't
think you could here good right dude I
could hear like a bat
suddenly I turn from a human into a bat
with an erection
bro I could hear oh my god dude I could
hear us I could hear a tree fart in
France I could hear a snail hiccup in
[ __ ] Nova Scotia son do when you are
listening you know in 1998 or whatever
when you know when a woman says that
she's willing to go in the other room
and play with her breasts so that you
can pleasure yourself in the next room
and you're allowed to listen to that
hello dude I could he I've never heard
so well in my whole life I could hear
things that my grandmother used to think
about and she'd already been dead for a
couple years I could hear things dude I
could hear the past I could hear it
Chabad crane riding through town you
know on the UM on a horse about the
Redcoats I could hear it all and that's
one thing Armour about being young and
but anyway that's what our skosh reminds
me of that let's hear a little bit more
thank you for calling sir we're talking
about who we won't have lunch with and I
can tell you right now that would be
Socrates well first thing is I've
postponed it is this Jordan Peterson
this sounds like Jordan Peterson doesn't
it
let's keep listening come up with some
excuse so I could get to suffer to
suffer as a way better chance to talk to
people you could be there longer and
everything's taste better than lunch but
after that like Socrates
he's just so fascinating I mean this
dude literally chose to die on the sword
of his own friggin like principles he he
was accused of introducing new gods and
corrupting the youth by just making
people question through Socratic you
know method of questioning which is
something I'm absolutely in favor of as
it's helped me and my friends
well mostly just our interests everybody
but he's just amazingly knowledgeable
and wise like not smart wise so I think
wise people are there's something key
about
and I think that where he didn't write
down anything that was another thing
about Socrates she didn't write down
nothing oh man he runs through my dad a
little bit that dude you know I don't
[ __ ]
but onward so Plato reinterpret
everything I want to hear word-for-word
what the hell came out of Socrates no I
think it's one most influential games
out there well thank you for that call I
appreciate that coming out of Canada man
I love Canada can we make more Canada's
do I would love to we could trade half
of these countries and make them
Canada's and I would absolutely love it
thank you for calling Socrates you know
I don't know that much about Socrates
but I'm gonna put him on my learning
list I'm gonna put Socrates on my
learning list man you know right now I'm
reading a book called why we sleep and
it's pretty fascinating but I would love
to learn a little bit more about
Socrates thank you for calling that's
who you would have lunch with actually
you'd like to have dinner you said what
could be a little bit longer and that's
the truth let's hear another call Thank
You Sophie oh joy
I was just thinking about who would I
have dinner with thanks for thinking
about that Johnny and for everybody the
hotline if you want to call and be a
part of the show somehow nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three that's
how you get involved in this past
weekend onward Yanni
and I no time a big kiss for Walt Disney
man Walt Disney mm-hmm that mousy man
huh he liked him crazy rides he like
Cinderella
he likes snow white that lady shades
some apples and slept over there you
know a little trap house with a bunch of
little soldiers running around let's
hear more she was not a maid an empire
I'm not one number one that would be the
coolest thing to ask him like how is did
that but - he was into the Dark Arts man
he was doing drugs if Darlene and make
an Alice in Wonderland and the grumpy
and all those guys that guy was on drugs
no one can look at me in the eyes and
tell me that he wasn't high as hell you
know that's pretty fascinating you know
uh he might have been on some dope who
was he hanging out with Muhammad Ali
damn that's crazy I don't even know that
I'm surprised Cinderella don't have
[ __ ] bigger shoulders honor if that's
the case but you never know boy you
never
No comes midnight Mama's about to
[ __ ] fistfight a pumpkin you know
mama did it come come midnight you know
I'm saying if these glass fighting boots
don't fit I'm a [ __ ] I'm a shoulder
pest I'm a shoulder press a Squatch a
squash I mean I'm a shoulder press a
squash a Squatch squash squash not a
Squatch that would be interesting though
Walt Disney Walt Disney to think up all
of that and make something come true
yeah it's interesting to think man I you
know it's fascinating it's just to have
some of your dreams start to come true
man you know even this weekend dude
honestly like you know I got to have my
name my name is on the bond though I'm
surprised they even had a thing on this
theater but my name was out there on it
on that marquee and I was pretty cool my
name's never been on that marquee before
so to have that was pretty cool
you know just to see it it's not and it
didn't make me feel like I'm great it
just made me feel it just made me feel
some pride you know it made me feel like
you know you go so long with your name
being on like I mean man cuz here's the
thing in the beginning your name is in
such your name is in some shady places I
remember right my name is in a bathroom
wall like I remember I go to the club a
couple weeks in advance or months in
advance and I write hey I'm gonna be
performing here on these dates and just
graffiti the [ __ ] toilet wall telling
people to come out dude I remember doing
a show up in North Dakota or South
Dakota one time whichever one of those
has Mount Rushmore and I think they keep
moving it back and forth honestly so I
wish these Dakotas would figure out
where they want those [ __ ] those
fancy heads at but they had a parrot in
there in the bar dude this was three
years ago
maybe two they had a parrot dude I went
to the show they had probably nine
people showed up one of the guys that my
opener was a beautiful Native American
gentleman and uh he he ran a weekly
night called Custer's last
stand-up so that's awesome as hell I
think and and they had a parrot in this
bar that a parrot a real parrot one you
see you know on the fruit loops or
something you know and he he was on a
parrot stand in the bar and you could
talk to him if you wanted to the only
thing I had a sign is say you can't call
him names and man it's so funny you say
you can't call something names and
immediately that's what people want to
do and dude I swear to god bruh huh
right in the middle of the show man one
person to go to the bathroom so that's
about 14% of the audience got up walked
by that parrot and you heard the dude
was walking by call it a [ __ ] and that
parrot lost his bird brain and then the
bartender's got upset they threw the man
out 14% of the audience out on the
street just because he couldn't he just
couldn't he couldn't recognize that sign
you can't call a parrot a [ __ ] that's
the only rule they had in the joint
there's something about us man as humans
you tell us we can't we want to do it
and it's the same thing you tell us we
can't like even in something as small as
oh you can't you can't call the parrot a
[ __ ] and I'll be damned if i slipping
by to take a Whizzer and I'm gonna drop
that hang me inch on that parrot but
also they tell you you can't achieve
your goals or your dreams and you'll try
to do that you know it's just funny it's
that it's almost well like how do we
start to find a way to stack the deck
against ourselves in order to better our
chances to achieve because some of us
work better from behind the eight-ball
you know I work best with my feeder to
the fire son I work best when I I work
best out of uncomfort
you know I think it's one of the reason
why I don't like to you know I get
worried about feeling you know I get
worried about um I get worried about
feeling confident in myself sometimes I
get worried about not confident I get
worried about feeling uh it's not
confident I get worried about feeling
that maybe proud of myself or something
or feeling because I'm worried if I just
that I bet it'll kill my drive or
something
you know if I if I start to if I start
to think that I'm doing well then I'm
afraid that I bet it my lose my my
ambition my Drive you know I think
there's I don't know what that is off to
think more about that let's take another
call that came in a dinner guests lunch
guests actually homeward zo7 here and
what's up Evan thanks for calling
brother Canada who these Canucks boy
they coming in hot I'm telling you man
build that wall to the north boy these
ice backs are rolling through I'm joking
you guys are uh welcome you are welcome
legally you are welcome here homeward
fan Ontario Toronto who would I have
lunch with from the past but who I'm
intrigued by your EURion sir because
you're coming from a Canadian
perspective so I'd like to hear this
Canadian perspective homework it's a
good one uh [ __ ] I'd have lunch with
Christ be like bruh what's up
how'd it all go down is this [ __ ] real
in this book or is it boxing was it
[ __ ] changed well do you first of all
brother you sent him really American
you're definitely easing down in it from
Canada into Detroit all of a sudden you
crossed uh you've crossed our country
lines because you start to use some real
profanity
around Christ even hypothetically you
don't want to be dropping you just
dropped a couple of f-bombs even
considering meeting up with that big sea
dog you know that's a good question
let's hear a little bit more of all your
thoughts on it you know it's funny man
you I think about this a lot you know
you know out here in Los Angeles in in
some of this industry and stuff that I'm
in there's it's not a rejection against
Christ but there's definitely you know
religion isn't super welcomed people
want to be offended or people want you
know a lot of this is vibe out here
sometimes I feel like the oh you're
gonna offend oh you can't have you know
there's something weird about faith you
know or in some areas people are like
thoughts and prayers that kind of
feeling like that but man I feel like
faith is just such a healing thing for
people yeah I feel alone I feel
hitchhiking when I you know if I don't
have some kind of a faith and I say now
you know as I even talk about this I
realize that my faith isn't very strong
right now and then it can really be
tightened up and but ya to feel I mean
the you know having faith that's a free
parent you get a free parent I meant I'm
not thinking I'm out here in this world
that's all for me this is all on my back
that I have no point that I'm that I
don't have an umbilical cord to some
sort of being now Jesus Christ man that
was the most popular guy in my area
growing up you know I think you do does
do is a great role model he I think he
could be the Son of God I think a lot I
think you know his brother could be
who's the little chubby guy that
positive baby that little fruit that bad
boy eating fruits in the diaper Buddha
maybe Buddha's his brother and mother
nature is their sister and yin and yang
or their Asian cousins and you got this
one big beautiful family of people that
when we feel alone we don't have to or
when we feel like we're not partisan
we don't have to I can't and look I know
some people out there a theists and
stuff and they don't want to believe in
anything and that's you know and I just
I can't understand understand it but I
also come from a place where I think
I've felt alone a lot and so if you're
telling me that there is a free /
there's a free being a free body a free
parent a free love a free heart out
there in the universe that will help me
not feel alone man k man that's a
lottery ticket that I don't have to
scratch man I'll take that all day I'll
take that all day because I want to be a
part of something bigger I don't want to
be a part of just myself you know and I
want to leave here and I want to say I
want to feel something again I want to
feel something again even if it's just
the feeling of if your spirit touching
the spirit of your parents or your
grandparents or of your sister or if one
of your ancestors or somebody else is
saying just a feeling of your spirit
bumping into somebody else is in another
world that's safe and normal and
comfortable maybe not even normal some
some new normal I don't know I'll take
that chance man [ __ ] I'd love to be a
ghost bro Duke could you imagine if we
get to be ghosts imagine being ghosts
you eat everything you eat just falls
right onto the floor
I would love that
I think Jesus Christ would be a great
guest I think he'd be great to talk to I
think that'd be a nice person to sit
down and have lunch with you know I
think it's a great role model you know I
I don't want to not have any faith man I
feel like it's it's I don't want to not
have any and now I'm I hope I'm open to
figuring out where that faith lies you
know one thing I was interesting for me
was when I started to travel and go to
other countries and see that other
people believed in different date
in different gods oh it was not fair to
me to then think oh well none of these
people go to heaven or none of these
people go to an afterlife are only my
God is the only one
umm but you got to believe in something
good I mean I ain't accepting these cats
believing in the dark arts you know that
thinking all the treasures right here on
earth that's tricky man that's it just
seems cold I just seem and look I'm open
to learn and uh but for me the way the
religion has always been most
comfortable in my life in my environment
when I grew up was Catholicism or
Baptists you know Presbyterians did I
thought Presbyterians were honestly
lesbians I didn't know I thought I
didn't know I mixed it up when I was
young dude now I hear those bells ring
and I would you know I'd be like dang
they got a lot of ladies heading over
there a lot of ladies boy gonna be
packing into that building cuz I thought
Presbyterians were you know straight-up
lesbians but but that's different
all right let's hear more hey Theo this
is Kobi from Rome New York hey Kobe from
Rome New York um I just wanted to call
in and answer the question you had about
who I would go to lunch with um and I
know I said he didn't really want family
members but I gotta say man it wouldn't
be my dad yeah he passed away when I was
15 from complications with diabetes
oh man I'm sorry to hear that dude I'm
sorry to hear that Cody I bet he I bet
he loved you to the end of the world man
I but he's still out there loving you
and that's another reason now here's a
reason why I want there why I need
something else out there because it's
not here here's why here's a here's why
and this makes it not even about me
I'm glad you you that were you and I are
thinking about this together right now
Cody because now why do I want there to
be an afterlife
so that your dad can still be alive out
there in some regard loving you
that's why so then you
even about me it's not even about I
don't need an afterlife for me now I
don't need there to be a heaven for me I
don't need there to be another realm
where our spirits go or find comfort now
I need there to be one for you or not I
need I know I want there to be one for
you so that Cody and his father will get
to have some moments again that you'll
get to you know you know you know feel
your father put his hand on the back of
your neck right there you know there's
something magical about that when your
dad puts all his hand on your neck it's
the same thing I think when you see dogs
they bite their children by the neck and
so there's something right in there
that's where those nerves are where we
connect to our family and so now I don't
need an you know what now I you this is
all answered so much of my thoughts
because I don't need it for me now it's
not even about me why do I want to have
faith now because I want to have faith
to somebody else this is cool man damn
dude this is cool thank you for calling
let's hear more he was a double amputee
in a wheelchair a double amputee in a
wheelchair dude so he was really that's
like X Games bro your dad was doing the
X Games before maybe it was even
realistic man homework and I took care
of him a lot and because of that I never
really got to never really got to know
them as much as I would want to yeah
yeah losing your father at that age man
you're just not old enough or my father
passed at 16 you're just not old enough
to act
you're almost old enough to start to
really get to know him to ask him
questions that a man would I asked you
know um so I'd really like to sit down
and have a meal with him just kind of
like you were saying uh just kind of
heaven tell me anything you know
anything from his past anything that was
important to him so I could kind of have
that in my life but yes it would
definitely have to be my dad yeah I'm a
longtime listener first-time caller so
this is pretty cool man
all right thanks Bo thanks for
everything you do thank you but thanks
for calling him man I mean to cut you
off but
you know I appreciate it Wow dude how
crazy now how crazy now what and what a
what do what a what a wonder what a
crazy answer we're thinking of that now
I don't need if somebody's like oh do
you believe in heaven well I think there
could I'd love for there to be one
because I know there are people out
there who want to see their loved ones
so if it means that I gotta suffer
through another life to another
experience then I'm willing to do it man
that's that's cool dude that's [ __ ]
cool bruh you just helped me think of
one of the best answers of you know and
that's teamwork dude that's what that's
what we get when we are thinking and
feeling together bro I'm telling you and
maybe I'm crazy right now and I'm amped
up but now you know what I don't like
because you know what I've been feeling
I've been feeling stressed out recently
because I get nervous sometimes we're
you know putting your voice out there in
this there's such de such this vibe out
there and the media that you can't have
no religion you can't have a [ __ ]
faith man [ __ ] that [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] anybody who tries to tell you
you need to feel alone
you're telling me I can get training
wheels on my heart come on man
I'll take them all day now do I know
exactly how I feel and some of that and
where I stand and who's the boss and you
know in Tony Danza Jesus Christ Alibaba
you know and um you know Jerry Lawler or
whatever no I don't I don't but I'm
gonna know I'm gonna be a part of it
while I'm here I'm gonna learn while I'm
here what do I have to lose and also who
cares what I have to lose I'd love for
there to be I'd love for there to be a
heaven so that other people can live out
man come on that's cool bro thank you
for calling let's keep some calls
rolling in here dude here we go hey yo
what's up mrs. face at a Pasco
Washington hey faith out of Pasco
Washington and this is a call wheel you
know I like to know who's listening to
the podcast and so faith is calling in
Thank You faith I'm just over here
slicing up some kielbasa
oh you mess around some kielbasa ha
faith okay you out there chirping on
that sausage huh yeah they're [ __ ]
around with that Clark homework no he's
listening and I'm a caregiver so I'm
taking care of the elderly and every
night i work night shift every night oh
that's beautiful
you know we have such a this there's a
huge epidemic going on right now in
America you know just talking my mom
about this today I want to you know my
mom she married and she married an older
man you know she's married to him now
and he has Alzheimer's and he was in the
war he was in a couple Wars and mr.
Charlie and some people you seen him on
my Instagram story and there's a video
on YouTube and I'll share it this week
on Twitter about my family where you can
get to see my family and what they're
like and Mister Charlie's in there and
he was in a war and he got trigger
finger pretty bad and he wears these
mittens you know he wears these you know
adult mittens but my mom has to take
care of me as Alzheimers you know and
they don't have any money they don't
have any any income and they have some
you know my mother works but it's not a
lot of income and then also reminds me
dude there's a man that's been taking
advantage of my mom making her work and
not paying her fairly I don't think so
we might have call that [ __ ]
this week that makes me mad sorry but
anyhow you know there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of people out there who
having to take care of their spouse
who's who are struggling a lot of
caregivers and it's a beautiful job and
a lot of people can't afford the care a
lot of spouses
for the care so my mother can't go do
anything she can't go do anything
without mr. Charlie being there you know
so she got to go ride or paper around
and stuff she got to have mr. Charlie he
got to alzheimerís he got to be in that
shotgun seat you know she just got him
straddling in he's just bouncing around
so he's just straight up I having
flashbacks and ducking grenades you know
dodging AIDS and you know eating
invisible MREs just in his brain you
know in the same time they're just
trying to you know you know drop off
some news on wheels magazines out here
to these different gas stations and
whatever and a lot of people but it's
because it's not you know there's no
there's no way to get care for them you
know my mother doesn't make an S maybe
there's not enough money there to get
pay for somebody to care for them all
day so anyway a lot of people are
dealing with family members with
dementia that's what I'm saying in a
sweet that you care about these people
onwards I listened to your podcast man
it sure does help my shifts go by a lot
faster there are these people I think
you know they have Alzheimer's dementia
so they're not like the usual folks we
walking around but I'm also and and then
they fight her no really Wow oh my gosh
dude I'm so excited about Justin Poirier
boy that Louisiana bad boy you know that
crazy crawfish easy he's supposed to
fight a Nate Diaz more I'm an amateur
and so I'm still making my way up there
but hey man I do what you got to do make
it to the top I guess I also have a
daughter and Wow see you up there is my
lady right there hundred dollar baby
right here that's my girl right there
that hundred dollar baby you about to
get up there and get it on put it on am
camming did I will cheer you on
I want to see I would love it if you
could um email me in a video of you
whenever you go fight some time it's
just producer email producer at Theo von
th e ovo end com I'd love to hear that
that's amazing Wow
to know that you're out there you know
just taking care of these dimensions
during the day and you out there getting
de minute at night I love it that's
beautiful now that's that's a very
bright area of the Dark Arts there and I
love what you're doing thanks for coming
in and thanks for listening to the
podcast so yo man I'm coming let you
know who's this new podcast please Matt
Matt gee I'm a welder down here in South
Carolina I build caterpillar tractors
dang Matt well thank you dude thanks for
calling in I never ridden on a
caterpillar tractor I've ridden on the
John Deere you know I used to work over
there do soybeans and corn and cotton
over off the Delta of the right off the
levee over there and um over near Deer
Park Louisiana and Vidalia and uh a man
I've always had fun on on some of those
tractors onward Matt hey you know a week
i'ma listen all kind of podcast I heard
you on the show Rogan show yeah man I
love Joe Rogan you know I actually got
to speak to on the phone today I called
him and any answer didn't I was so
nervous kind of but he's like we talked
for a couple minutes and then he's I got
to go man shooting arrows in my backyard
and it was just like the most Joe Rogan
thing that could ever be happening but
he just put a picture up of him and his
golden retriever enjoying uh a run today
the first run they'd been on in like six
weeks and he's an inspiring guy you know
so I'm glad that you listen to him
let's hear more everyone your podcast in
probably about three weeks Wow dude damn
that's crazy man that's too much bro
that's almost as much of my voices I've
heard my whole life just going in my
head let's hear more oh you like your
laughs you keep it upbeat you keep it
keep it at effort a simple man some
prayer vital at that but you know I deal
with a bunch of [ __ ] and a bunch
of politics a bunch of backstab and a
bunch of brown-nose and you know in the
workforce nowadays things like Scott a
hair
instead of golden knee pads and a
brown-nose ski anywhere and that ain't
my game anyone I do so I got to work I
stay in my face I will I listen you keep
me laughing and I appreciate it man oh
thanks Matt you know it's uh you know
you're so right about some of this it's
like if we don't define our lane what is
my lane
what is Matt's lane you go to work you
want to be you know how I you know you
are you happy when do you define what
your happiness is because people go out
there chasing but dude you can chase
[ __ ] all your whole life you know
you can die with ten million dollars in
the bank and own the whole [ __ ] town
but you don't know all your
grandchildren's names you know where you
don't know you don't know
you missed your um you know you missed
uh you were you were out of town on a
business trip you know when your mother
took her last breath you know and these
aren't things these are threats or
anything but it's like you have to
define your lane because what do you
want to spend as we start to get older
and especially as we just as we start to
be alive it's like what do we want to
spend our time doing you know and I love
listening to this guy Gary Vaynerchuk
this weekend but um but some of its like
man I want to I want to be business
savvy son and I want to be proactive but
I want to also I want to be careful
because I don't you know I don't want to
I don't want to be a
business I want to be a person I'm
saying the Lord didn't put me or whoever
didn't put me down here
you know fati what's his name
fruit fatty with the diaper Buddha you
know Big Buddha didn't put me down here
you know or David who are some of these
other gods and stuff that they have oh
here's one of my favorites is the Indy
Ganesh the Indian God do get a cool
Ganesh statue it's like this elephant
and it pushes all the obstacles out of
your life isn't that a cool one India
has some beautiful deities I mean
beautiful beautiful people man you want
to meet a beautiful culture it's India
beautiful culture but look man I
appreciate you [ __ ] listening dude
and look if [ __ ] gets haywire bruh
here's what I say snap you up a couple
hits LSD or a little 8-ball and take
that [ __ ] forklift for a ride you
know what I'm saying them big bad brown
nosers out there I say you forklift up
one of those [ __ ] Mercedes Benzes or
whatever you know I'm saying just do
some we do some [ __ ] wheelies with
that [ __ ] on those Forks set that put
that thing all the way to the top boy do
man we used to what we used to do is
when I used to work at a I used to work
at a welding shop man I worked outside
and we have to you know it was piping
services we'd have to put you know put
rubber on these piping on pipes fitters
on pipe fittings so it wouldn't corrode
each other when the fitting that went on
when of the brace went onto the pipe and
my buddy we get high dude and look I've
you run in that forklift my buddy would
get high and he'd be on the I'd move him
up on the pallet to put something up and
then what I would do is I go outside and
put the pallet all the way to the top
he'd be about 12 feet and dude he'd be
up there at 12 feet high as [ __ ] and
he'd be so scared bro dude I someone
watching him be up there just scared let
me do telling the boss what you gonna
tell the boss that you has [ __ ] bro
that you [ __ ] smoking them Giants on
the job cam I came out
man thanks for calling - you just made
my day bro and do look you keep
caterpillar in bro
you keep caterpillar on man you build
them tractors dude you build them things
man and if I see when I see a damn
caterpillar I'm gonna think of yo ass
daddy boy be good man all right let's
move on - we have the best and worst
weekends and and I wanna you can hit the
hotline and let us know if you had the
best or worst weekend don't hit us with
a regular weekend just hit us if you if
it was the greatest weekend or the worst
weekend let us know why try to keep it
around a minute
that number is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and we have
our winner for July let's hear that
thing right now and this I thought it
was stink last time and then I remember
I got an email from and said he said my
name is not stink and then I realized
yeah that would be a crazy name to have
but also be dope boy you know I'm saying
it's my fellow right here stank Johnson
get a [ __ ] nostril hitter yeah boy
you know but uh he's our winner let's
hear if you didn't hear what happened in
last week let's hear it all then for I
do both weekend or worst weekend I'll
let you be the judge
I'll write you let me be the judge Oh
more strength um last weekend went out
for the bar on Saturday night or Friday
night and met this girl
long story short guest nice talking to
her and she's out with some friends and
her friend got very drunk and she was
there by herself
and this girl was nine months pregnant
come to signed up just found out that
baby daddy had been cheating on her and
nine months pregnant that is a person
that's a full-term brother that is so
that's two people you're talking to
let's hear more
just one of the people is still hiding
inside of one of the other one so that's
basically woman and then also somebody
playing hide-and-go-seek ended up with
the world hooking up with her taking her
back to my place
she stayed the whole weekend with was
your place a hospital because that
seemed like the kind of place you would
take a nine-month a pregnant lady home
with me and then Monday good she left I
got a text from Les you just popped out
that little baby so when the visitor at
the hospital and says congratulations
you know kind of feel like my big help
do this Jesus and you had to take it
there at the end but that's all right
that look that I don't know if that's
the best or worst worst weekend but I'll
tell you this that man manned up and
went to the hospital see that lady and
and we're grateful stink we're gonna be
in touch and we'll send you a prize
package do we got um some of these
Correctional Center blue t-shirts for
this past weekend and we'll send you one
of those thanks so much for being a part
of things brother we appreciate it
we got another someone that called in
with the best or worst weekend here we
go
hey Theo Stephanie down in Daytona Beach
Florida
I just want to call and say thank you
for encouraging people to swim around in
their feelings because that's hard to do
sometimes you're welcome thank you for
calling and saying thank you and I know
you don't get a lot of female callers
because well I'll listen to your show
but anyway I wanted to tell you about
this wonderful week and I have this past
with him my boyfriend of six months took
me out for a birthday extravaganza
oh nice happy belated birthday to you in
pain funny bore City and uh we did a lot
of trying out and delicious food we went
to the aquarium and uh one night we're
out we're bar hopping we wrap around
this bar smoking a cigarette and this
homeless guy comes up to us and asked us
for cigarette and a few dollars cuz he
said he hadn't showered in a month I
said hey me too
and we had to laugh about Adam and my
boyfriend's okay man we'll buy you a
couple beers if you want to hang out for
a minute so
if this ends in a threesome this is
gonna be this might be back-to-back the
craziest months ever homeward we ended
up doing that shared some cigarettes
compared to this guy and then we ended
up taking this guy to a place called
Hamburger Mary's I know you know what
that is yeah I do it's a whole
homoerotic hamburger spot where you can
get meat and men homework it's a drag
queen bar so we said this big dude me
and my boyfriend down there and he's
such a generous man he goes and gets
like $20 in one for all three of us to
hand out to the drag queens while
they're doing their performance and Jack
means are dancing on us we're dancing on
them and just having a real magical time
and I just appreciated my boyfriend for
taking me out and showing me and this
homeless guy a great weekend I love that
I love that story you know one time I
had um thank you for calling with that
and and that is a great weekend and
that's your boyfriend treating you well
and I like hearing about that you know
it's nice to treat somebody that you
love well and it probably made him feel
really good to do that you know there
was a I got invited a loyola marymount
to him to be a judge on their Loyola
Idol Loyola Marymount Idol and it was
like their American Idol contest at
school and at the last minute they
called me said Theo can you bring two
extra judges and I'm like yeah my home
where I'm gonna get these boys there you
know and then suddenly an idea just
popped into my head you know and I
stopped by the park
I stopped by the park off of Wilshire
Boulevard in Los Angeles and Lincoln and
I picked up a couple of vagrants you
know a couple local vagrants bro one
dude was mid pissed when I [ __ ]
walked up to him do not respect that
you know there was a couple rich people
playing tennis right there on some fancy
Court and this dude he straight-up
[ __ ] water and plants right next to
him like a straight-up [ __ ] G bruh so
anyway I took two homeless gentlemen you
know without homes sans Casas and took
those dudes to Loyola Marymount so
there's like eight hundred students
sitting there and you know there's like
twelve students that are gonna perform
and the curtains open and suddenly
there's me and two gentlemen without
homes homeless gentleman and were the
judges and there we are the judges for
this whole contest so these dudes went
from being in a park they got in my car
we drove there I got paid you know I
think I got paid 300 bucks I broke them
each off $40 and and but what a crazy
day for those guys you know what a crazy
day for those guys so some of that kind
of stuff is fun we had another call that
came in let's hear it hey Theo listening
to your last episode man you got me
thinking about the church band man oh
yeah that's a very wily vehicle to died
I was in a church band that was part of
the church van no part of the church
dude they the back seat man that was for
like the goth kid Oh back seat OVAs
Gotham huh them god Goths you know what
I'm saying you know there are a lot of
them goth kids they look like they have
been eaten charcoal and [ __ ] with their
eyes like they've been hiding charcoal
briquettes you know like they've been
[ __ ] you know dipping doing dip but
they've been dipping briquettes up in
their eye sockets homeward jerking off
as a real thing man got me thinking of
that that time when I was younger you
know sitting there with my neighbor like
my younger brother and we were in like
the fifth the fourth row and the goth
kids were in the fifth behind us jerking
off that's America right there brother
if you don't have a couple goth kids in
the seat behind you Jo and son are you
living life that's what I want to know
are you living life let's take another
call here here we go Casey oh this is
Grace called from Minneapolis Minnesota
hey grace thanks for calling I was just
there um so hopefully you enjoy it and I
was just wondering I actually work at a
church and so if you want to come this
Sunday let me know oh I'm sorry I just
heard this call just now but thank you
very much for the invite homework and
all that you love your nieces and
nephews and let you're close to your
family so I'm just curious about all
that is a professional comedian and I
know you believe
a higher power but I know you said that
you just kind of leave used to a good
guy so I'm just curious what and maybe
really is not pastor a Christian Church
maybe that's an assumption but anyways
just trees hey thank you for the call
and it's so funny that this you know
this call and uh and I was just talking
about some of this stuff because I
haven't heard any other calls that came
in until now producer Nick was listening
to him this week
ya know I you know my nieces and nephews
and my family members go to church you
know and they love it they go down there
in Baton Rouge and you know month and
they you know uh and what one of the
things that I see when I go down there
with them and spend time is that it's
just a fun thing you know a lot of times
some religion gets bad name you know
these far-right really you know you know
people that are you know to the point of
judgment that's where it gets scary
is when there's too much judgment but
hell we're all judgmental and it's all a
battle you know but it's uh it's night I
just like seeing I remember her doing
fun stuff when I was a kid when I'll go
to the church and eating big Donuts in
there and you know having old people
kind of touchy on the cheek and say
things to union they looks they kind of
scared you a little bit but you had fun
you run around with your friends and
wearing fun you know you know church
clothes and being snazzy and so lemme
sneak on a little bit of Old Spice from
your daddy or something put a little bit
of Old Spice on your neck you know do
something fun or just I don't know I
remember being it as a young child it
was a nice chance to see people on the
weekend sometime you don't get to see
people on the weekend and then suddenly
you got to see your friends in good food
and people being together yeah I don't
see anything wrong with that at all but
thank you so much for the invite and I'm
sorry that I didn't get to this email
earlier I had to fly out early this
morning I flew back to Los Angeles so I
didn't get a chance to check it out
let's take a one more call here guys I
got to get out here I got to go to an
AME
just a little bit but let's take another
call right here here we go CEO homie oh
man this is Dillon in South Carolina had
a crazy weekend not so crazy but for me
it's out of the ordinary thanks for
calling Dillon so this might be in or
this past best or worst weekend contest
let's hear what happened homeward uh um
had a loss of life in my family about
two years ago and settlement just came
out a lawyer called me actually wanted
to come to the house and talk to me
came on over and I'll drop that
knowledge in 98 grand coming my way man
and that wasn't a sound effect man I got
an email at the same time I hope that
lawyers hitting me up dude I might be in
this settlement wow that's interesting
man 98 grand that's a lot of money dude
that's that straight-up big hitter
that's that you know that's that uh
that's like a damn leprechaun just you
know fell asleep in your house and and
and all the the bullion in his pockets
just rolled out on your floorboards
let's hear more
I got about 60 days to think about what
I'm doing with with myself and I know
that you know it's not often you get
this kind of opportunity in life I'm a
33 for kids married I've got a wow what
a blessing in that money could be really
helpful bunch of chickens a couple coats
you know I'm loving life man but man
just don't know like what what do you do
but that kind of paid for what what how
you turn that into some I don't wanna I
don't wanna work till I'm old crusty and
rusty boss didn't [ __ ] how do you do
something with that man what would you
do with that they don't let us know what
you would just do if use a regular Phil
I don't know where you're sitting now
but what if you sitting on 98 grand and
didn't know what to do with yourself
well I'll tell you this I do not have 98
grand what would I do with myself if I
had if somebody just said you had that
money I would buy a piece of real estate
I would buy uh you know some type of uh
maybe rental property if you want to
deal with that kind of stuff now here's
the thing people always talk about
rental property flip this you make so
much money it's a lot of responsibility
as well you can also have a lot of
responsibility to do finding tenants all
that kind of stuff
you're a landlord you know you're not
just a rental property owner you were
also a landlord and that is another job
um I mean what would I do with that
money now if I had four children
I'm sure the filter that I'd be thinking
through would be divided by four that's
for sure uh you know I would probably if
I had four children I bet I'd set aside
a little maybe five grand for each kid
that they don't know about and that
they're not allowed to tell the other
kids about once they get it maybe once
they all hit eighteen they would all get
the money at once because you give it to
one of them then the other ones are
going to be expecting it they're gonna
be making decisions based on the fact
that they're gonna be getting that money
at some point in their life so I maybe
do that and then no you want to plan
ahead you know what this might go right
back to the Gary Vaynerchuk
Gary Vee you know he might know better
maybe I would check out some of his
videos because he seems to have a better
similar to what it's like you know that
Gary Varner took to get in there and see
what he would do if you came in to 100
grand a week a minute yeah if you came
in 200 grand what would you do with it
what would you do you had four children
you don't want to work forever I would
buy some Amazon stock dude that's what I
would do I would buy some Amazon stop
I think Amazon can own half the world I
would buy some Amazon stock but outside
of that I don't know what I would do
with it but if you seem like you're
doing contrib we have some chickens and
goats you don't want to do something or
out I don't think I wouldn't want to do
something that would affect my lifestyle
immediately that I wouldn't be able to
adapt into comfortably because then if
it didn't stay that way I might be upset
you know and I might you know you don't
wanna you don't want to get too
comfortable you know one of my friends
told me a long time ago they say yes
if you're coming to somebody you don't
want to buy the nice car you don't want
to buy the nice car um I don't know
let's put that to our listeners if you
came into 98 grand right now what would
you do what would you suggest this man
does he's got four children you heard a
scenario he got a
well chickens couple goats you know I'll
eat like I tell you this I know them
chickens and goats gonna live a little
bit longer they gonna live high on the
hog a little bit cuz they ain't gonna be
dinner soon
you got 98 grand what would you do what
would you do man that's a great question
we can leave out on that with some other
great calls that came in I want to thank
everybody that came out last weekend I
appreciate it
in Minneapolis that's it man
you know I'm tired I'm gonna get and I'm
gonna settle down and get some rest
tonight and um and I'm just grateful
that that uh I'm grateful we got to do
this for another weekend I'm grateful we
got to do this for another week
I'm grateful in here there's people out
there that are enjoying what we're doing
here
you know we're creating like a curiosity
I think man it's exciting it's exciting
for me to show up here each week and and
see what you guys are up to thank you
for hitting the hotline thank you for
listening to this episode and I will see
you guys and I'll see you guys I'll see
you guys here next week be good to
yourselves you probably deserve it man
you probably do I'm gonna try to be good
to myself tonight and get some rest
here we have Brooks Doherty again
[Music]
[Applause]
belches 200 miles away
Memphis 200 miles away there is 200
miles I just sit on laughing smile
please wear that old evil
she had a chip on his shoulder since the
day she left upon thought their daddy
[Music]
she meet her mama cry
she didn't
that's about
Oh
Jim thought she needed someone gift
[Music]
she played my heart just like a guitar
and she didn't skip a beat now
sheesh
200 miles away
Memphis 200 miles away
[Music]
200 miles thank you guys so much man I
love you guys
I'll see you next week